WITH YOU.ORG AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE WOMEN CAN GO AND FAMILIES
CAN GO AND GET SUPPORT AND
SERVICES.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE AS YOU ALL
KNOW ECONOMISTS ARE NOW
PREDICTING THAT CHILD POVERTY,
THE RATE OF THAT IS GOING TO GO
UP.
MANY OF THESE STATES NOW BANNING
ABORTION DO NOT HAVE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE EXTENDED
MEDICAID FOR WOMEN GIVING BIRTH.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO FIGHT FOR THESE DISADVANTAGED
WOMEN WHO WANTED TO GET AN
ABORTION AND COULDN'T BECAUSE OF
THE STATE THEY LIVE IN AND THEIR
CHILDREN WHO ARE GROWING UP IN
POVERTY.
>> WELL, WE'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
THESE WOMEN AND THEIR FAMILIES
FOR 50 YEARS.
THE ABORTION INDUSTRY AND WHAT
WE HEAR ON CAMPUSES ALL THE
TIME, THAT TELLS WOMEN THAT
ABORTION IS A SIMPLE SOLUTION TO
ALL THEIR PROBLEMS.
WHEN IN FACT WE BELIEVE IN
HELPING THOSE WHO SUFFER NOT
ELIMINATING SOMEONE WHO MAY
POTENTIALLY SUFFER.
I THINK YOU HELP SUFFERING.
YOU HELP ALLEVIATE THE
SUFFERING, YOU DON'T SAY, WELL,
WE'RE GOING TO SOLVE THAT BY
JUST PRESCRIBING ABORTION
BECAUSE ABORTION DOESN'T END
POVERTY.
ABORTION DOESN'T TAKE HER OUT OF
THAT ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP THAT
SHE FINDS HERSELF.
THAT'S HARDER WORK.
THAT'S WALKING ALONGSIDE SOMEONE
AND SEEKING SOCIAL JUSTICE WITH
THAT PERSON AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE
PREGNANCY CENTER MOVEMENT FOR
NEARLY 50 YEAR.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT THE
REALITY IS, I THINK IT'S NEARLY
HALF A MILLION KIDS END UP IN
FOSTER CARE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF THOSE
WERE KIDS THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
MOTHER WANTED TO ABORT AND CAME
FROM A DISADVANTAGED HOME BUT
THE REALITY IS YOU SAY THAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON THIS BUT SO
MANY KIDS STILL END UP ABUSED,
NEGLECTED IN A BROKEN FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AND THE REALITY IS
THE GOVERNMENTS IN THESE STATES
DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES ON THE
BOOKS SUCH AS PAID FAMILY LEAVE,
SUCH AS THE EXTENDED MEDICAID TO
HELP WITH THESE SITUATIONS.
>> WE CAN TALK ABOUT THOSE
POLICIES BUT THE QUESTION IS, IS
THE SOLUTION TO CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE TO KILL THEM?
NO ONE WOULD ARGUE IN OUR
SOCIETY THAT BECAUSE A CHILD IS
IN FOSTER CARE, THEREFORE, THEIR
LIFE IS UNWORTHY OF LIVING.
THAT'S THE POINT WE'RE MAKING IN
THE PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT EVERY
SINGLE DAY WHEN WE ARGUE FOR
PROTECTION AT CONCEPTION THAT
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE MAY SUFFER
IN THEIR LIFE, IT DOESN'T MEAN
WE SHOULD SNUFF THEM OUT OF
EXISTENCE, THAT WE SHOULD
VIOLENTLY END THEIR LIFE WHEN
THEY'VE DONE NOTHING WRONG.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE IMPORTANT
PART TO START THE CONVERSATION.
>> I WANT TO GET TO THAT BECAUSE
YOU BRING UP TWO IMPORTANT
POINTS, YOUR VIEW THAT LIFE
BEGINS AT CONCEPTION BUT ALSO
YOUR VIEW THAT EVEN BANS IN
MISSOURI IN THE CASE OF RAPE OR
INCEST, YOU SUPPORT THAT.
SO UNDER THOSE LAWS, A
12-YEAR-OLD COULD BE RAPED AND
STILL BE FORCED TO CARRY THAT
BABY TO TERM.
IS THAT WHAT YOU WANT?
IS THAT THE KIND OF THING YOU
SUPPORT?
>> I ABSOLUTELY DON'T WANT
12-YEAR-OLDS TO BE RAPED.
I DON'T WANT --
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THAT'S THE
REALITY OF THE WORD WE LIVE IN.
>> ABSOLUTELY, WE DEFINITELY SEE
THESE TRAGEDIES AND NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB IN ENFORCING
PENALTIES ON THESE PEOPLE WHO
COMMIT --
>> BUT DO YOU THINK THE
12-YEAR-OLD SHOULD CARRY THAT --
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IN
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST A HUMAN
BEING BASED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THEIR CONCEPTION.
WE DON'T ISSUE BIRTH
CERTIFICATES IN OUR NATION AND
GIVE GOLD STARS OR SILVER STARS
AS TO HOW YOU WERE CONCEIVED.
WE SAY, NO, YOU ARE A HUMAN
BEING WITH RIGHTS AND YOU SHOULD
BE PROTECTED.
>> SO WHEN I HEAR YOU --
>> THAT'S WHAT WE BELIEVE AS A
MOVEMENT.
I THINK YOU SHOULD SPEAK WITH
FRIENDS LIKE MY FRIEND RYAN WHO
WAS CONCEIVED IN RAPE AND MOTHER
MADE A COURAGEOUS DECISION TO
PLACE HIM WITH AN ADOPTIVE
FAMILY AND TALK TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS WHO HAVE FAMILIES WHO
WERE CONCEIVED IN SEXUAL ASSAULT
THAT EVERY SINGLE TIME WE TALK
ABOUT ABORTION IN AMERICA, WE
BRING THESE HUMAN BEINGS UP AS
IF THEIR LIVES DON'T MATTER AND
THEY DON'T HAVE VALUE.
I SIMPLY REJECT THAT.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE SAYING,
THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT SHOULD A
12-YEAR-OLD CARRY A BABY TO TERM
IF THAT 12-YEAR-OLD WAS RAPED.
YOU THINK, YES, THAT IS THE
CASE.
WE HAVE TALKED TO MANY WHO WERE
BORN EVEN THOUGH THEIR MOTHER
WAS RAPED OR EVEN THOUGH THEIR
MOTHER CONSIDERED AN ABORTION
AND CHOSE NOT TO.
WE TALKED TO PEOPLE ALL ACROSS
THE SPECTRUM.
YOU ARE ARGUING YOUR CATHOLIC
FAITH DICTATES THAT THE LIFE
BEGINS AT THE MOMENT OF
CONCEPTION.
THERE'S A SYNAGOGUE IN FLORIDA
THAT HAS FILED SUIT CLAIMING
THAT IN JEWISH LAW ABORTION IS
REQUIRED IF NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH, MENTAL OR PHYSICAL
WELL-BEING OF THE WOMAN.
WHY SHOULD YOUR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS TRUMP THEIRS?
>> IT'S NOT MY FAITH THAT TELLS
ME LIFE BEGINS AT CONCEPTION.
IT'S SCIENCE.
96% OF BIOLOGIST AS GROW THAT
THE MOMENT --
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT --
>> A UNIQUE HUMAN LIFE COMES
INTO EXISTENCE.
>> WHERE ARE YOU GETTING THE 96%
OF BIOLOGISTS?
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
>> THAT'S A STUDY FROM CHICAGO
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO.
>> MY PRODUCER WILL LOOK THAT
UP.
I READ MANY OPINIONS PREPARING
FOR THIS SEGMENT -- I JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR WITH OUR VIEWERS.
>> THAT'S SCIENCE.
CAN YOU DEBATE WHETHER OR NOT
THAT HUMAN LIFE HAS VALUE.
MY FAITH TELLS ME THAT THAT
HUMAN LIFE --
>> THERE IS NO CONSENSUS ON
SCIENTISTS.
>> THAT FAITH TELLS ME THAT
HUMAN LIFE SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
BUT SCIENCE TELLS US AT THE
MOMENT OF CONCEPTION WHEN EGG
AND SPERM UNITE, A UNIQUE
GENETIC CODE COMES INTO
EXISTENCE.
THAT'S NEVER EXISTED BEFORE AND
WILL NEVER EXIST AGAIN.
THAT IS, IN FACT, THE MOMENT
WHEN A HUMAN BEING COMES INTO
EXISTENCE.
THAT IS INDISPUTABLE.
>> THERE'S NOT A CONSENSUS AMONG
SCIENTISTS.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NOT.
LET ME WALK YOU THROUGH WHAT
MANY SCIENTISTS HAVE SAID.
I READ ALL SIDES OF IT TODAY
FROM VARIOUS SCIENTISTS.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS A GENERAL
VIEW THAT A BABY, A FETUS
REACHES VIABILITY BETWEEN I
BELIEVE IT IS 24 TO 28 WEEKS IN
THE WOMB.
THERE IS A VIEW THAT WHEN THE
EGG MEETS THE SPERM AND BECOMES
AN EMBRYO IT IS JUST A CLUSTER
OF CELLS.
IT IS NOT.
>> I'M JUST A CLUSTER OF CELLS.
WHAT MAKES ME DIFFERENT.
>> I HEARD YOU SAY THAT.
WHAT ABOUT AND THIS IS -- I AM
NOT TAKING A POSITION BUT I LIKE
TO CHALLENGE --
>> THIS IS FUN.
>> EXACTLY.
>> I LIKE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
>> SO IF A WOMAN GOES IN, SHE
WANT -- SHE CAN'T GET PREGNANT
ON HER OWN SO IN A LAB THEY HAVE
TO TAKE, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE TO
DO IT SCIENTIFICALLY IN THE LAB
AND PUT THE EGG AND THE SPERM
TOGETHER TO CREATE AN EMBRYO.
IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO GET
THIS WOMAN PREGNANT A DOCTOR
DESTROYS THE EMBRYOS BECAUSE
THAT'S JUST WHAT HAPPENS.
IS THAT DOCTOR A MURDERER?
>> YES, THE DOCTOR IS ENDING
HUMAN LIFE.
WE DON'T DEFINING IT AS MURDER
IN OUR --
BUT THAT IS ENDING HUMAN LIFE.
>> SO IVF CLINICS SHOULD BE
BANNED?
>> IT DEPENDS ON THE PROCEDURE
USED.
>> SOMETIMES THAT'S JUST WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> THERE'S ALSO THE QUESTION OF
INTENTIONALITY AS WELL.
THERE ARE --
I HAD A QUESTION POSED WHERE
SOMEONE SAID IF A WOMAN IS
HAVING A MISCARRIAGE DO YOU
CONSIDER HER BEING A MURDERER?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
UNINTENDED AND IS SAD.
AND JUST BECAUSE IF A WOMAN
MIGHT BE, YOU KNOW, AT RISK FOR
MISCARRIAGE WE DON'T CONSIDER
HER A MURDERER BECAUSE SHE HAS
AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION.
>> THAT WASN'T MY QUESTION.
I SEE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BUT I'M
TALKING ABOUT A DOCTOR WHO WAS
TRYING TO HELP A WOMAN GET
PREGNANT AND THROUGH THE PROCESS
EMBRYOS HAVE TO BE DESTROYED.
THAT DOCTOR IS A MURDERER EVEN
THOUGH --
>> NO EMBRYOS SHOULD EVER HAVE
TO BE DESTROYED IN IVF.
>> OKAY, WELL, IT DOES HAPPEN.
THAT'S JUST THE BOTTOM LINE.
AND ALSO THERE ARE SO MANY
EMBRYOS FROZEN AS WELL THAT
THESE IVF CLINICS OVERSEE SO
WHAT ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT
INTENTIONALITY.
I WOULD SAY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PRO-LIFE LAWS, THIS ISN'T EVEN
DISCUSSED.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS
NEXT IN A POST-ROE AMERICA THE
DISCUSSION OF IVF ISN'T ON THE
TABLE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ENDING HUMAN
LIFE INTENTIONALLY, DISMEMBERING
CHILDREN WHO HAVE LIMBS, WHOSE
ARMS AND LEGS HAVE TO BE REMOVED
FROM A WOMAN'S BODY AND PUT BACK
TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHAT WE